Is there anything more agonizing than having to wait for something important? You know that feeling of hoping for good news while bracing for the worst? Time seems to crawl in periods of high-stakes uncertainty, such as for a job applicant waiting to find out whether they got their dream job, or a high school senior waiting for word from colleges, or a patient awaiting biopsy results. And since COVID-19 entered our lives, the whole world has gotten a crash course in waiting and worrying,
还有什么比等待重要的事情更让人痛苦的吗？你知道那种既希望有好消息，又在为最坏的情况做准备的感觉吗？在高风险的不确定时期，时间似乎过得特别慢，比如求职者在等待是否得到了梦寐以求的工作，高中生在等待大学的录取通知，或者病人等待活检结果。自从新冠疫情进入我们的生活，全世界都经历了一场关于等待和担忧的速成课，
as we've all hoped for the end of this agonizing pandemic. What makes waiting so stressful? How does the stress of waiting differ from other types of stress? What kinds of waiting periods are the most difficult? Do some people have an easier time waiting than others? And what's the relationship between waiting and worrying? Is worrying always bad? And if you're in a period of anxious waiting,
因为我们都盼望着这场痛苦的疫情能够结束。是什么让等待变得如此令人压力倍增？等待带来的压力与其他类型的压力有何不同？什么样的等待期最难熬？有些人是否比其他人更容易度过等待期？等待和担忧之间有什么关系？担忧总是坏事吗？如果你正处于焦虑的等待期，
are there strategies you can use to lessen your anxiety and make the time pass more easily? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Kate Sweeney, a professor of psychology at the University of California, Riverside. Dr. Sweeney researches how people cope with acute uncertainty. Her lab has studied people experiencing tense times in their lives,
有没有什么策略可以减轻你的焦虑，让时间过得更容易些？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是加州大学河滨分校的心理学教授凯特·斯威尼博士。斯威尼博士研究人们如何应对极端的不确定性。她的实验室研究了人们生活中经历的紧张时刻，
including law school graduates awaiting news about the bar exam, patients awaiting biopsy results, and voters awaiting the outcome of a presidential election. In recent years, she's become interested in exploring how getting into a state of flow can help people cope with this type of uncertainty. She also studies how doctors can talk to their patients to lessen the patient's anxiety. She has published dozens of peer-reviewed research studies and received APA's 2016 award for Distinguished Scientific Early Career Contributions to Psychology. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Sweeney.
包括等待律师资格考试结果的法学院毕业生、等待活检结果的病人，以及等待总统选举结果的选民。近年来，她开始探索进入“心流”状态如何帮助人们应对这种不确定性。她还研究医生如何与病人沟通以减轻病人的焦虑。她发表了数十项同行评审的研究，并获得了美国心理学会2016年心理学杰出早期科学贡献奖。感谢您参加我们的节目，斯威尼博士。
Thanks so much for having me. Let's talk about how the stress of waiting differs from other types of stress. For example, you might think that receiving a bad medical diagnosis would be more stressful than waiting for the diagnosis, but that's not necessarily what you've found. So what makes the experience of waiting particularly stressful? Yeah, that's exactly right. So just as an example, studies find that if you ask women who have gone through, for example, treatment for breast cancer, you know, what was the hardest part of that experience?
非常感谢邀请我。让我们谈谈等待带来的压力与其他类型的压力有何不同。例如，你可能认为收到糟糕的医疗诊断结果比等待诊断结果压力更大，但你发现的情况并非一定如此。那么，是什么让等待的经历变得特别有压力呢？是的，完全正确。举个例子，研究发现，如果你问那些经历过乳腺癌治疗的女性，她们经历中最困难的部分是什么？
Many of them will say it was the period of uncertainty that preceded the diagnosis, not the diagnosis, not the treatment, which can be very unpleasant. So there's definitely truth to what you said. What we think, and we have some data now to support this, is that waiting combines two really challenging states of mind, not knowing what's coming, uncertainty, and not being able to do much or anything about it, so a lack of control. And neither of those are comfortable states for humans to be in. and when you combine them into these waiting periods, it really kind of boosts waiting into this
她们中的许多人会说，是诊断前那段不确定的时期，而不是诊断本身，也不是治疗，尽管治疗过程可能非常不愉快。所以你说的确实有道理。我们认为，现在也有一些数据支持这一点，等待结合了两种非常具有挑战性的心理状态：不知道未来会发生什么（不确定性），以及对未来几乎无能为力（缺乏控制感）。对于人类来说，这两种状态都不好受。当你把它们结合到这些等待期中时，它确实会把等待提升到一种
extra suffering kind of state compared to other kinds of stress, which may be difficult in other ways, but waiting does seem to kind of tap into some existential challenges for humans in that it combines those two really challenging states. And you also study worrying, which is obviously related to stress uncertainty in waiting. You published a paper a few years ago called The Surprising Upsides of Worry that got some media attention. what are the surprising upsides of worrying? So worry is actually super helpful. That might be hard to imagine if someone is feeling worried.
比其他压力更痛苦的状态，其他压力可能在其他方面也很困难，但等待似乎触及了人类的一些存在主义挑战，因为它结合了那两种极具挑战性的状态。你还研究了担忧，这显然与压力、不确定性和等待有关。几年前你发表了一篇名为《担忧的惊人益处》的论文，引起了一些媒体的关注。担忧有哪些惊人的益处呢？其实，担忧是非常有帮助的。如果有人正感到担忧，可能很难想象这一点。
It's not very pleasant. And that's exactly how it's helpful, in fact, is that it draws our attention to something that might befall us in the future. It motivates us through its very unpleasantness to prevent in some way that future bad event. Now, the trouble is when we're waiting, we often can't do anything about the future event.
这确实不太令人愉快。事实上，这正是它有益的地方，因为它将我们的注意力引向了未来可能降临在我们身上的事情。它通过这种非常不愉快的体验来激励我们，以某种方式预防未来的坏事发生。现在，问题在于当我们等待时，我们往往对未来的事件无能为力。
So if you've taken an exam, you've undergone a medical test, you know, there's really nothing you can do while you're waiting for that news to change your fate. Your fate is sealed. You just don't know it yet. And so worry in that case can get a little stuck. It kind of doesn't help us in the same ways that it does when, say, we're worried about a car accident and so we put on our seatbelt or we're worried about breast cancer so we get a mammogram. Those are very useful moments of worry. During waiting periods, it doesn't quite have that same useful function. and that is, I think, one of the other things that makes waiting so hard.
所以，如果你参加了考试，做了医学检查，你知道，在等待消息时，你真的无法改变自己的命运。你的命运已定，只是你还不知道结果而已。在这种情况下，担忧可能会陷入僵局。它不像我们担心车祸而系上安全带，或者担心乳腺癌而去做乳房X光检查那样有帮助。那些是担忧非常有用的时刻。在等待期间，它并没有发挥同样有用的功能。我认为，这也是让等待变得如此艰难的原因之一。
So it's almost a kind of controlled worry, a worry under the circumstances that is going to protect you. That's right. And it's not to say that worry has no function in, for example, waiting periods. One of the things that worry can prompt us to do is to, for example, plan out, you know, maybe worst case scenarios and make sure we're ready for them. So it's not exactly prevention. It's not quite the job worry wants to do for us. but it still can be useful to kind of get your ducks in a row, make sure that you're prepared for the worst case. And that can be a little bit comforting. It feels like grabbing back some control from the universe in these moments where we have so little control. You've talked before about how some of your research started as me search, which is a great term we've heard other guests use on this podcast.
所以这几乎是一种受控的担忧，一种在特定环境下能保护你的担忧。没错。这并不是说担忧在等待期内毫无作用。担忧可以促使我们做的一件事是，例如，规划出最坏的情况，并确保我们为之做好了准备。所以这不完全是预防。这并不是担忧想为我们做的全部工作，但它仍然有助于理清思绪，确保你为最坏的情况做好了准备。这可能会带来一点安慰。在这些我们几乎无法掌控的时刻，这感觉就像是从宇宙中夺回了一点控制权。你之前提到过你的研究是如何从“自我研究”开始的，这是我们在本播客中从其他嘉宾那里听到的一个很棒的术语。
What were the situations in your own life that inspired your interest in this topic? I am certainly a worrier by nature, as so many people are. get it from my mom. So we share that in common. So that's been kind of, you know, a lifelong reality. I think, you know, to some extent, everyone has their moments of worry, but mine might be a little more profound than others. There have been, though, also some very specific experiences that I think informed my work on waiting and worry. One that came kind of right around the time that I started to think about these issues was being on the academic job market, which is long and tedious and stressful process that, you know, begins somewhere around August of the year before you want the job.
你生活中哪些情况激发了你对这个话题的兴趣？我天生就是一个爱担忧的人，就像许多人一样。这是从我妈妈那里遗传的。所以我们有共同点。这对我来说一直是一种终身的现实。我认为，在某种程度上，每个人都有担忧的时刻，但我的可能比其他人更深刻一些。不过，也有一些非常具体的经历影响了我对等待和担忧的研究。其中一个发生在我开始思考这些问题的时候，那就是在学术就业市场上找工作，这是一个漫长、乏味且充满压力的过程，你知道，从你想要工作的前一年的八月左右开始。
And in my case, went through about January. And it was one of the most difficult kind of uncertain periods of my life. I feared often that I would be unemployed with a PhD. Of course, thankfully, it worked out and here I am. But that experience was one that I came back to often as I was thinking about how we cope with these experiences of uncertainty and what just makes them so difficult. Were you looking at worrying during your graduate studies as well, or was it really just the experience of waiting for this, the first job? Yeah, so certainly my research has been in some ways consistent from the early days of graduate school. I came there to work with a professor who was studying at the time one piece of the waiting experience, and that is bracing for the
就我而言，一直持续到一月左右。这是我一生中最困难、最不确定的时期之一。我经常担心自己会成为一个失业的博士。当然，谢天谢地，结果还不错，我走到了今天。但那段经历是我在思考我们如何应对这些不确定性经历以及是什么让它们变得如此困难时经常回想起来的。你在研究生学习期间也在研究担忧吗，还是仅仅是因为等待第一份工作的经历？是的，我的研究在某些方面确实从研究生院早期开始就保持了一致性。我当时去那里是为了跟随一位教授工作，他当时正在研究等待体验的一个部分，那就是为最坏的情况做准备，
worst, which is a kind of nitpicky phenomenon that happens while we're waiting, where your expectations tend to go from very optimistic at the start or before a waiting period and then plunge into pessimism at the moment of truth when we're convinced we fail the exam or we have cancer or whatever the fear might be. And so I studied that phenomenon, as small as it may be, for quite a long time with a lot of focus. And then as I came into this job at UC Riverside and again, having had that experience of uncertainty during the job market, I started to kind of broaden out the view and start to think about, yes, we brace for the worst while we're waiting, but what else are we doing? And what else is going on during those experiences that makes it so
这是一种在等待时发生的吹毛求疵的现象，你的期望往往在等待期开始前非常乐观，然后在真相大白的那一刻陷入悲观，那时我们确信自己考试不及格，或者得了癌症，或者任何可能存在的恐惧。所以，我研究这种现象，尽管它可能很小，但持续了很长时间，并且非常专注。后来我来到加州大学河滨分校任职，再次经历了找工作期间的不确定性，我开始拓宽视野，开始思考：是的，我们在等待时会为最坏的情况做准备，但我们还在做什么？在这些经历中还有什么在发生，使得它们变得如此
difficult? So that was kind of the evolution of my research program. There's a stereotype that women are bigger worriers than men. Is there any truth to that? Is waiting for uncertain news more difficult for some people than for others? And how does personality or other demographic factors figure into worrying? So we actually did publish a paper just a few years ago with some pretty convincing evidence that women report more worry than men. I think that's a pretty important distinction. It may be that for various reasons, be they evolutionary or socialization, kind of how we're raised, that women may, on average, perhaps experience a bit more of that particular kind of negative emotional experience.
困难？这就是我研究项目的演变过程。有一种刻板印象认为女性比男性更爱担忧。这有道理吗？等待不确定的消息对某些人来说是否比其他人更困难？性格或其他人口统计学因素在担忧中起什么作用？我们确实在几年前发表了一篇论文，提供了一些非常有说服力的证据，表明女性报告的担忧比男性多。我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。可能是因为各种原因，无论是进化还是社会化，也就是我们是如何被抚养长大的，女性平均而言，可能确实会经历更多那种特定的负面情绪体验。
But it's a little bit hard to parse that out because it is also the case that women learn from an early age, very, very early age, in fact, research shows that. that it's kind of okay to cry and it's okay to be worried and it's okay to be anxious and, you know, little boys may be less so. Certainly that was true. Historically, I would like to think maybe that's changing, but it's a pretty pervasive gender difference in how we raise kids. So I think that, yes, there is quite a bit of evidence, again, that women are at least willing
但这有点难解析，因为事实也是，女性从小就学会了——事实上，研究表明，从很小的时候起——哭泣是可以的，担忧是可以的，焦虑也是可以的，而小男孩可能就不那么被允许。历史上确实如此。我希望这种观念正在改变，但在我们抚养孩子的方式上，这是一种相当普遍的性别差异。所以我认为，是的，确实有相当多的证据表明，女性至少愿意
to report more worry than men. It's also the case that personality matters. So people who have an overall tendency towards what psychologists call neuroticism, which is essentially emotional instability combined with a negative emotional kind of tendency. Unsurprisingly, those folks tend to deal with more worried than folks who are less neurotic or less lower in neuroticism. There are other kinds of individual differences we would refer to them as that matter. One big one is what we call dispositional optimism.
报告比男性更多的担忧。性格也很重要。所以，那些总体上倾向于心理学家所说的“神经质”的人，本质上是情绪不稳定加上负面情绪倾向，不出所料，这些人往往比那些神经质程度较低的人处理更多的担忧。还有其他我们称之为个体差异的因素也很重要。其中一个大因素是我们所说的“特质乐观”。
And that just means kind of an overall tendency to be bright and cheery and kind of expect the best. And even if it doesn't work out the way you want, it's going to be okay. anyway, you know, those annoyingly happy folks that we all know, the higher you are in that tendency, that dispositional optimism, the easier time you have in the face of uncertainty. Now, having said all of that, no one finds all uncertainty to be comfortable. As I said earlier about worry, it's useful. And so we really can't escape it entirely. And I, you know, anecdotally have yet to find a person who hears about my research and says,
这仅仅意味着一种总体上开朗、乐观并倾向于期待最好的结果的倾向。即使结果不如你所愿，也没关系。总之，你知道，那些我们都认识的令人讨厌的快乐的人，你在这种倾向（特质乐观）上的得分越高，你在面对不确定性时就越容易度过。话虽如此，没有人会觉得所有的不确定性都是舒适的。正如我之前关于担忧所说的，它是有用的。所以我们真的无法完全逃避它。而且，我凭经验还没发现有谁听到我的研究后说，
I don't know why you'd even study that. It's not that hard for me. so I think it's a fairly universal experience at some level. Does being an optimist, I mean, having a positive outlook on the world, protect you from worrying to optimists, worry less than pessimists, or is everybody, you know, we all just worry. Yeah, optimists do worry less than pessimist, on average. Again, there are exceptional moments where, you know,
“我不知道你为什么要研究这个。这对我来说一点也不难。”所以我认为这在某种程度上是一种相当普遍的体验。做一个乐观主义者，也就是说，对世界持积极态度，能保护你不去担忧吗？乐观主义者比悲观主义者担忧得少吗，还是说我们大家，你知道，我们所有人都会担忧？是的，平均而言，乐观主义者确实比悲观主义者担忧得少。当然，也有一些特殊时刻，你知道，
the situation is so extreme that everyone worries. But on average, yeah, optimism, being an optimist in that way, that kind of cheery, dispositional way, does, it is protective. In fact, it's, it's one of the rare areas in psychology where it's pretty hard to find a downside to that particular kind of personality trait. You might gamble more aggressively. Like, that's the one finding about dispositional optimism that is, that's negative. But pretty much everything else about it is protective. Now, I want to make a really important distinction, and that is being that type of person doesn't mean that you always think things will go well for you. That's what we
情况太极端了，每个人都会担忧。但平均而言，是的，做一个乐观主义者，那种开朗的、特质上的乐观，确实具有保护作用。事实上，这是心理学中罕见的几个领域之一，很难找到那种特定性格特征的负面影响。你可能会赌博得更激进。比如，这是关于特质乐观的唯一一个负面发现。但除此之外，它几乎在所有方面都是保护性的。现在，我想做一个非常重要的区分，那就是成为那种类型的人并不意味着你总是认为事情会为你顺利发展。那就是我们
call unrealistic optimism. And that is more of a kind of situational tendency to, you know, just expect the best when it's not really something you should be expecting. And that has all kinds of downsides. But that more, you know, kind of general disposition towards optimism and cheerfulness seems to be a pretty good thing if you can have it. Does worrying kind of level off with age? I mean, there are a lot of, you know, negative characteristics that many people have that as you get older and you know, we always talk about how the baby boomer is the older folks are, they feel more comfortable in their skin, basically. I mean, does that happen with worrying as well? We're just sort of, okay, I got this. I've been here before. Yeah, I don't know actually
所说的“不切实际的乐观”。这更多是一种情境倾向，你知道，当你不应该期待最好的结果时，却偏偏期待最好的结果。这有各种各样的坏处。但那种更普遍的、对乐观和开朗的倾向，如果你能拥有它，似乎是一件相当不错的事情。担忧会随着年龄的增长而平息吗？我的意思是，许多人身上有很多负面特征，随着年龄的增长，你知道，我们总是谈论婴儿潮一代，那些老年人，他们基本上在自己的皮肤里感觉更自在。我的意思是，担忧也会发生这种情况吗？我们只是觉得，好吧，我能应付。我以前经历过。是的，我其实不知道
of any really good data on that question, but you might assume so from other research on aging. One of the things, one of my favorite, I guess, findings in psychology, though it's not my area, really, is that we do generally tend to get happier as we get older, at least from sort of the point of middle age onto later adulthood and older old age. It's maybe counterintuitive, but it's the evidence is pretty compelling. And there are lots of good reasons why, you know, as you said, you kind of get a better perspective. You're a little bit less concerned about kind of, you know, achievement and making remark on the world and kind of settling in more to a comfortable place in life. That's, you know, not entirely a faithful interpretation of the
关于这个问题有任何真正好的数据，但你可能会从其他关于衰老的研究中推测出这一点。尽管这不是我的领域，但我最喜欢的心理学发现之一是，我们通常确实会随着年龄的增长而变得更快乐，至少从中年到成年后期和老年阶段是这样。这也许有悖常理，但证据相当令人信服。有很多很好的理由，你知道，正如你所说，你获得了一种更好的视角。你对成就和在世界上留下印记的关注减少了，更多地沉淀到一个舒适的生活位置。这，你知道，并不完全是对
very complicated research on that topic. But it's very reassuring for me. to know that, you know, likely I will get happier as I get older. It's a one thing to look forward to. And, you know, again, I think worry likely goes along with that. Now, of course, there's huge variability. We probably all know older people who are, you know, beset by a lot of anxiety and worry. And that's a tough place to be at that age. But on average, it does seem like people tend to, as you said, mellow out kind of as we get older. There's a really old adage, probably a lot of our listeners have never heard it, but it's the kind of thing my grandmother used to say, a watched pot never boils.
关于该主题的非常复杂的研究的忠实解读。但这对我来说非常令人欣慰，知道，你知道，我随着年龄的增长可能会变得更快乐。这是一件值得期待的事情。而且，你知道，再次强调，我认为担忧很可能也会随之减少。当然，存在巨大的差异。我们可能都认识一些被大量焦虑和担忧所困扰的老年人。在那个年纪，那是一个艰难的处境。但平均而言，正如你所说，人们随着年龄的增长似乎确实倾向于变得温和。有一个非常古老的谚语，可能我们的很多听众从来没听过，但我祖母过去常说：“心急吃不了热豆腐”（直译：注视的锅永远不会沸腾）。
So does time slow down for everybody who's worrying? I mean, that is kind of what that describes that if you watch the water, it's never going to boil. If you walk away, it will boil. Yep, that's exactly right. Yeah. So in general, you know, we've all, I'm sure, had the experience in lots of contexts where if you're having a good time, time flies.
所以时间对每个担忧的人来说都会变慢吗？我的意思是，这正是它所描述的，如果你盯着水看，它永远不会沸腾。如果你走开，它就会沸腾。是的，完全正确。是的。所以总的来说，我相信我们在很多情况下都有过这样的经历：如果你玩得很开心，时间过得飞快。
And if you're, you know, experiencing something frustrating or boring or tedious or unpleasant, time seems to crawl along. And then it can feel like an hour. And that's the case with waiting and worry. well. So we have found that when people are suffering during a waiting period, they're worried, they're having a difficult time coping, that it feels like the end of that waiting period will never come. Now, unfortunately, there's a bit of a downward spiral that can occur because it's also the case that when you feel like this waiting period will never end, it can heighten that
如果你正在经历一些令人沮丧、无聊、乏味或不愉快的事情，时间似乎过得特别慢。然后它可能会感觉像一个小时。等待和担忧也是如此。所以我们发现，当人们在等待期间受苦时，他们感到担忧，难以应对，就会觉得等待期永远不会结束。现在，不幸的是，可能会出现一种恶性循环，因为当你觉得这段等待期永远不会结束时，它会加剧你所经历的
distress that you're experiencing. So we've worked pretty hard to find good ways to kind of break that cycle, but it's somewhat inevitable, I think, in those moments where you are feeling particularly worried. So I think that segues us into the concept of flow, right? That's something that you have named and have been looking at. Can you explain what flow is and how it can help people who worry? Yeah, so flow is a concept that's been around in the research literature for, gosh, I forget how old I am, but it's probably more than 50 years at this point, a very long time, longer than I am alive. And Mike Chiksetmi Hai is the kind of father of that concept of flow. He did studies some really interesting in-depth studies many, many, many decades ago about
痛苦。所以我们非常努力地寻找好的方法来打破这种循环，但我认为在那些你感到特别担忧的时刻，这是某种程度上不可避免的。所以我认为这引出了“心流”的概念，对吧？这是你命名并一直在研究的东西。你能解释一下什么是心流，以及它如何帮助那些担忧的人吗？是的，心流是一个在研究文献中存在了——天哪，我忘了我多大了，但这可能已经超过50年了，很长一段时间，比我的年龄还大。米哈里·契克森米哈赖是心流概念之父。他在几十年前做了一些非常有趣、深入的研究，关于
creative types and the folks who can sit and paints and, you know, forego food and never get up to go to the bathroom and, you know, they'll cramp up and they barely notice it because they're so in the zone in the activity they're doing. And so he really identified that kind of absorbed flow state that many of us experience in in our everyday lives as well, not just, you know, the artists among us. And so we have picked up that concept and really applied it to this, this idea of waiting. You know, as we just talked about, one of the difficult things about waiting is the persistence of time passing slowly and not passing as quickly as we would like it to when we are, you know, eager to find out some information.
创意类型的人，那些可以坐着画画，你知道，放弃食物，从不起来去洗手间，你知道，他们会抽筋，但几乎没有注意到，因为他们完全沉浸在他们正在做的活动中。所以他确实识别出了那种吸收性的心流状态，我们许多人在日常生活中也会经历，不仅仅是，你知道，我们中间的艺术家。所以我们采纳了这个概念，并真正将其应用于等待这个想法。你知道，正如我们刚才谈到的，等待的困难之处之一是时间过得缓慢的持续感，当我们渴望找到一些信息时，它并没有像我们希望的那样快速流逝。
And so, you know, what better to do than to do something that will make time feel like it's flying by? And there are lots of things we can do that might be, you know, a little bit distracting that, you know, get us away from watching that pot as the saying goes. But it is especially useful if you can get into that kind of exquisitely distracting state of flow where, you know, you lose self-consciousness, you are completely out of your head, you are completely in the activity. And in fact, we know that time seems to really just pass by in a moment when we're in that state. In fact, when people ask, like, how do I know what my own flow activities might be? I say, think about the thing you can't do if you need to leave the house anytime soon because you'll lose track of time and end up being late wherever you're going. And that's a pretty good indicator that that's a flow activity, which is different for everyone.
所以，你知道，还有什么比做一些能让时间感觉飞逝的事情更好的呢？我们可以做很多事情，可能，你知道，有点分散注意力，你知道，让我们远离盯着那个锅，正如谚语所说。但如果你能进入那种极其分散注意力的心流状态，那就特别有用，你知道，你失去了自我意识，你完全跳出了自己的头脑，你完全沉浸在活动中。事实上，我们知道，当我们处于那种状态时，时间似乎真的在瞬间流逝。事实上，当人们问，比如，我怎么知道我自己的心流活动可能是什么？我说，想想如果你很快需要离开家，你不能做的事情，因为你会忘记时间，最终无论去哪里都会迟到。这是一个很好的指标，表明那是一项心流活动，这对每个人来说都是不同的。
So, yeah, that's a good test and really points to that time perception aspect of flow experiences. It sounds like it almost relates to a meditative state. I mean, is that part of what you advise people who are worriers, that if you can focus in the way that you might mindfully meditate, that that will help? We have studied mindfulness meditation as well in this context, or in this context, excuse me. And it's interesting. Flow and mindfulness are cousins, I would say.
所以，是的，这是一个很好的测试，确实指出了心流体验的时间感知方面。这听起来几乎与冥想状态有关。我的意思是，这是你建议那些担忧的人的一部分吗，如果你能以你可能正念冥想的方式专注，那会有帮助吗？我们也研究过正念冥想，在这个背景下，或者在这个背景下，抱歉。这很有趣。心流和正念是表亲，我会这么说。
They certainly share a lot in common. They are both a form of focused attention, which might not, again, intuitively seem like something that would be helpful, but it turns out that attention is a really powerful force and if we're letting it kind of carry away to worries and ruminations and unpleasant thoughts, that's going to hurt us, whereas if we can focus it towards something productive and pleasant, that's probably going to help us in those moments. So they're similar in that sense. They're also similar in the sense that they are beneficial in lots of ways for reducing stress,
它们确实有很多共同点。它们都是一种专注的形式，这可能，再次强调，直觉上看起来不像是有帮助的事情，但事实证明，注意力是一种非常强大的力量，如果我们让它被担忧、反刍和不愉快的想法带走，那会伤害我们，而如果我们能把它集中在一些富有成效和愉快的事情上，那在那些时刻可能会帮助我们。所以它们在那个意义上是相似的。它们在很多方面对减轻压力、
for improving our emotional state. How they are different, I think, importantly, is that mindfulness is really about total awareness of your experience in a given moment. And that's, you know, really the focus of most meditations is, you know, maybe focus on the breath, but also kind of notice your thoughts passing by, notice feelings that arise, notice sounds in your environment. Whereas flow is really the opposite in that particular way, where you are so absorbed in an activity.
改善我们的情绪状态也是有益的。我认为它们的不同之处在于，正念确实是关于在特定时刻对你的体验的完全觉知。而且，你知道，大多数冥想的重点确实是，你知道，也许专注于呼吸，但也注意到你的想法流过，注意到出现的感受，注意到环境中的声音。而心流在那个特定方面确实是相反的，你完全沉浸在活动中。
One term that comes up in the flow research is action awareness merging, which just means you and the activity are essentially one. There is like no kind of mental space between you and what you're doing. and that's really different. You won't notice anything going on around you if you're really in a flow state. And so the way I think about it is, I think mindfulness is a really important practice
心流研究中出现的一个术语是“行动与意识的融合”，这仅仅意味着你和活动本质上是一体的。你和你正在做的事情之间几乎没有心理空间。而且这真的不同。如果你真的处于心流状态，你不会注意到周围发生的任何事情。所以我对它的看法是，我认为正念是一种非常重要的练习，
for kind of getting good at managing worry, at reacting to worry in a way that doesn't kind of carry you away and take you down with it. And that's something that's very useful for sure in lots of parts of life. Flow I think of is more of like an in-the-moment solution. So I'm having a bad worry day. Today is a good day to get into that flow
对于那种擅长管理担忧、以一种不会把你带走并把你拉下去的方式来应对担忧。这在生活的很多方面确实非常有用。我认为心流更像是一种当下的解决方案。所以我今天是一个糟糕的担忧日。今天是一个进入那种心流的好日子
date. It might not help five minutes after you're finished with the activity, but it will be very helpful as you're in that moment and your worries shut down for a period of time. What about turning to friends or family for support? Is there any research on whether that's helpful during periods of acute uncertainty? It is. As it is during most times of life, social support is crucially helpful for our well-being and also our health. It's, you know, having people who you know can support you in difficult times predicts, longevity, for example, like how long you will live at the same level as something like smoking. So it's hugely important in general, therefore perhaps unsurprisingly, also helpful during the
状态。在你完成活动五分钟后，它可能没有帮助，但在你处于那个时刻，你的担忧在一段时间内关闭时，它会非常有帮助。那么向朋友或家人寻求支持呢？有没有研究表明这在极端不确定时期是否有帮助？确实有。正如在生活的大多数时候一样，社会支持对我们的幸福感以及我们的健康至关重要。它，你知道，拥有你知道可以在困难时期支持你的人，可以预测，例如，寿命，也就是你能活多久，其水平与吸烟等因素相当。所以它总体上非常重要，因此也许不出所料，在
stress of waiting and uncertainty. Maybe the more kind of interesting aspect of that social support during waiting, though, is that I think it's really hard to provide it well. So we need it when we're waiting. It can be really lonely sometimes, especially if you're waiting for something very personal. But people aren't always great at providing social support. in those moments where, you know, nothing is really happening. Like, you're waiting for that test result to come back. You know, people might feel like, I don't know, just wait. Like, it's coming.
等待和不确定性的压力下也很有帮助。不过，等待期间那种社会支持也许更令人感兴趣的方面是，我认为很难提供得很好。所以我们在等待时需要它。有时它可能非常孤独，特别是如果你在等待非常私人的事情。但人们并不总是擅长提供社会支持。在那些，你知道，什么都没发生的时候。比如，你在等待那个测试结果回来。你知道，人们可能会觉得，我不知道，等着吧。就像，它会来的。
You'll know in a day or two, you know, how this is going to turn out. Why are you thinking about it right now? Well, we've all been there. We know you can't not think about it. But as a, you know, social support provider, those moments can be really challenging. And we have found, in fact, that in a prolonged waiting period, specifically where law school graduates were waiting for their bar exam results for four long, torturous months, months, you know, their romantic partners did a pretty good job of supporting them shortly after
你过一两天就会知道，你知道，结果会怎样。你为什么现在还在想它？好吧，我们都经历过。我们知道你无法不去想它。但作为一个，你知道，社会支持提供者，那些时刻可能真的很有挑战性。事实上，我们发现，在一个延长的等待期内，特别是法学院毕业生等待律师资格考试结果的四个漫长、折磨人的月里，你知道，他们的浪漫伴侣在考试后不久做得相当不错，
the exam, you know, when there was stuff to talk about, essentially, and then right before they got their results, in the middle of that four months, they still needed the support. They weren't always doing well, and their romantic partners weren't showing up for them quite as much as they wanted them to in those moments. Oh, that makes sense. So you choose carefully who you're going to confide in and who's going to be your support. Spread them out. So this year has been marked by intense uncertainty and stress for many of us. At one point, we thought the pandemic might be over, but then the Delta variant showed up
你知道，当有事情可以谈论时，本质上，然后在他们得到结果之前，在那四个月的中间，他们仍然需要支持。他们并不总是做得很好，而他们的浪漫伴侣在那些时刻并没有像他们希望的那样为他们提供支持。哦，那说得通。所以你要仔细选择你要向谁倾诉，谁将成为你的支持者。分散开来。所以今年对我们许多人来说，标志着强烈的不确定性和压力。有一次，我们认为疫情可能结束了，但后来德尔塔变异株出现了
and breakthrough infections. Is it more stressful to wait through a period of uncertainty without knowing the end date, like the pandemic, as opposed to something like the bar exam results, where there's a date. You know that you're going to get an answer on a certain date. Yeah, that's right. So it's been interesting, actually, for me, just personally, as a researcher, to think about how my work on waiting applies to this global and very open-end kind of uncertainty that we're experiencing.
以及突破性感染。在不知道结束日期的情况下等待不确定时期，比如疫情，是否比像律师资格考试结果那样有日期的事情压力更大？你知道你会在某个日期得到答案。是的，确实如此。所以，作为一名研究人员，我个人思考我的等待研究如何应用于我们正在经历的这种全球性的、非常开放式的不确定性，这其实很有趣。
And as you pointed out, not just open-ended, but kind of almost cyclical where we have these periods where things seem to be going well and we think we might be out of it. And then we're plunged back into uncertainty again. You know, I think there is a similarity in many ways across different kinds of uncertainty, whether they are those structured sorts of waiting periods that I typically study where the end is known, or at least the end date is known, if not the result, versus, you know, this kind of situation with COVID and so many other things. where it's kind of open-ended.
正如你指出的，不仅是开放式的，而且几乎是周期性的，我们有这些时期，事情似乎进展顺利，我们认为我们可能已经走出来了。然后我们又陷入了不确定性。你知道，我认为在不同类型的不确定性之间，在很多方面都有相似之处，无论是那些我通常研究的结构化的等待期，其中结束是已知的，或者至少结束日期是已知的，如果不是结果的话，还是，你知道，这种与新冠病毒以及许多其他事情的情况。它是开放式的。
We've, for example, looked at cancer survivors' experiences as well, which is a different kind of open-ended uncertainty where it might come back or not, but you really don't know when that might happen. Whether it's harder or easier is a little tricky, I think, to be sure about. When we know that a waiting period will end, those last moments, hours, days, weeks,
我们，例如，也观察了癌症幸存者的经历，这是另一种开放式的不确定性，它可能会回来，也可能不会，但你真的不知道那什么时候会发生。它是更难还是更容易，我认为确定这一点有点棘手。当我们知道等待期会结束时，那些最后的时刻、小时、天、周，
however, it falls within your particular waiting period can be pretty torturous. You know, those final moments of truth, we all have a tendency to, you know, plunge into pessimism, plunge into a worst-case scenario thinking, to kind of have a difficult time coping. When there's no clear end, you don't kind of have that ramp up of distress in that same way. But you also don't get that kind of relief in maybe the middle of the waiting period, which is typically an easier time. We have found that waiting has a shape, such that the beginning and end is the hardest and the middle
无论它落在你的特定等待期内的什么位置，都可能非常折磨人。你知道，那些最后的真相时刻，我们都有倾向，你知道，陷入悲观，陷入最坏情况的思考，在应对方面遇到困难。当没有明确的结束时，你不会以同样的方式经历痛苦的加剧。但你也不会在等待期的中间得到那种缓解，那通常是一个更容易的时间。我们发现等待有一种形状，使得开始和结束是最难的，而中间
tends to be easier, when you're in one of these, like, endless waiting periods, like we're all in now for the end of a global pandemic, I don't even know what that will look like. You know, it's really hard to kind of know at what point you should be gearing up for the moment of truth. Like, there just is no moment of truth at this point, or there are many of them, I guess maybe, but no one singular end to our uncertainty. So the way that I've at least observed it, you know, again, somewhat anecdotally, not so much in data, is that I think that it creates it's more of a good day, bad day situation where rather than kind of settling into more of a pattern where it's hard at the beginning, you calm down a bit and then it gets hard at the end,
往往更容易，当你处于这些之一时，比如，无尽的等待期，就像我们现在都在等待全球疫情结束一样，我甚至不知道那会是什么样子。你知道，真的很难知道在什么点你应该为真相时刻做好准备。就像，在这一点上根本没有真相时刻，或者我想也许有很多，但没有一个单一的结束我们不确定性的时刻。所以我至少观察到的方式，你知道，再次强调，有点凭经验，数据不多，我认为它创造了更多的是好日子、坏日子的局面，而不是沉淀成一种在开始时很难、你冷静一点、然后在结束时变难的模式，
we just kind of do a bunch of little cycles of, you know, oh, hey, this is where we are. I'm kind of used to it. I've got my situation settled in a way that's comfortable. And then a week of, oh, no, this is awful and I can't handle this. And, you know, when will my kids get to go back to school or when will my job, you know, become in person again? Or when will I get my job back? And so I think it's unfortunately hard to find real relief for any length of time when the situation is constantly evolving and there's no clear end in sight. So what are you working on now? What are the next big questions that you want to answer?
我们只是做了一堆小循环，你知道，哦，嘿，这就是我们所处的。我已经习惯了。我已经以一种舒适的方式安顿好了我的情况。然后是一周的，哦，不，这太糟糕了，我无法处理这个。而且，你知道，我的孩子们什么时候能回到学校，或者我的工作什么时候，你知道，再次变成面对面？或者我什么时候能拿回我的工作？所以我认为，当情况不断演变且看不到明确的结束时，很难在任何长度的时间内找到真正的缓解，这很不幸。那么你现在在做什么？你想回答的下一个大问题是什么？
Yeah, I've been thinking a lot about that. You know, I've been studying this very focused question about like what is this thing that is waiting and how do we make it easier for about 10 years now? And, you know, it's felt like a big question at times. But I think after about a decade, we've answered a lot of the, the problem. that I kind of had at the beginning, there's more to do, but I think we know a lot now about waiting that we didn't know a decade ago. And so I've started to think about where to next. And there's really three big areas that my lab is focusing on now. One is flow, which we've already talked about. And it turns out that the world of flow research is huge and wild and wacky. That's very interdisciplinary, I guess. It's kind of a nice word for it, which means people from lots of different fields, often not even scientific fields, are interested in it. But that means that it's a mess. I mean, honestly, the research is kind of a mess.
是的，我一直在思考这个问题。你知道，我一直在研究这个非常专注的问题，关于什么是等待，以及我们如何让它变得更容易，大约10年了。而且，你知道，有时感觉这是一个大问题。但我认为经过大约十年，我们已经回答了很多，那个问题。我在开始时有一种，还有更多要做，但我认为我们现在对等待了解了很多，而十年前我们不知道。所以我开始思考接下来去哪里。我的实验室现在真正关注三个大领域。一个是心流，我们已经谈过了。事实证明，心流研究的世界是巨大、狂野和古怪的。这非常跨学科，我想。这是一个很好的词，这意味着来自许多不同领域的人，通常甚至不是科学领域的人，都对它感兴趣。但这意味着它是一团糟。我的意思是，老实说，研究有点乱。
And it's really hard to know what we know about flow. And it is this very kind of powerful, compelling experience that, you know, we all have. And I think we seek sometimes. But what exactly it is and, you know, what it looks like in the brain and the body, how exactly it benefits us and when we really don't have a lot of good evidence on that. So, you know, I became interested in flow because of waiting and because of its fit as a coping strategy during waiting periods. but now I and my graduate students have fallen down the rabbit hole a little bit and are interested in getting a better handle on what that exactly is.
而且真的很难知道我们对心流了解什么。它是这种非常，你知道，强大、引人注目的体验，你知道，我们都有。而且我认为我们有时会寻求它。但它到底是什么，你知道，它在大脑和身体中看起来是什么样子，它到底如何使我们受益，以及何时我们真的没有很多好的证据。所以，你知道，我因为等待以及它作为等待期间应对策略的契合度而对心流产生了兴趣。但现在我和我的研究生们有点掉进了兔子洞，并且有兴趣更好地掌握它到底是什么。
So that's one area. I'm also taking a deeper dive into worry and what exactly it is about worry during waiting periods that is so difficult. And that is work I'm doing with a collaborator at another University of California campus at Merced, Jennifer Howell, who's a longtime collaborator of mine. And we have some money right now to try to figure out, you know, when is it that worry is hopeful to us and not so disruptive to our lives? And when is it that really does become a problem for our health and well-being? And that turns out to be, as things
所以这是一个领域。我也在深入研究担忧，以及等待期间的担忧到底是什么使得它如此困难。这是我正在与加州大学默塞德分校的合作者詹妮弗·豪威尔一起做的工作，她是我的长期合作者。我们现在有一些资金来试图弄清楚，你知道，担忧在什么时候对我们是有希望的，而不是对我们的生活有那么大的破坏性？在什么时候它真的成为了我们健康和幸福的问题？事实证明，正如事情
tend to be in psychology, a more complicated question than might appear on the surface. And then the third big question is one that's a big, big collaboration that I'm really excited about thinking about patients, which in some ways I've been studying all along, but more as a virtue. And that's an interesting way to kind of think about patients, not just as like waiting calmly, but as something that we can kind of cultivate, that does have connections to philosophy and theology. And so a researcher at Baylor University, Sarah Schnichter is leading this big, big initiative to bring together researchers from across fields to kind of bring our perspectives on what the heck this thing is called patients, you know, what it looks like, how to get it.
在心理学中往往如此，这是一个比表面看起来更复杂的问题。然后第三个大问题是一个很大的、很大的合作，我非常兴奋地思考病人，这在某些方面我一直在研究，但更多是作为一种美德。这是一种思考病人的有趣方式，不仅仅是像平静地等待，而是作为我们可以培养的东西，它与哲学和神学有联系。所以贝勒大学的研究员莎拉·施尼希特正在领导这个非常大的倡议，将来自各个领域的研究人员聚集在一起，以某种方式汇集我们对这种被称为“耐心”的东西的看法，你知道，它看起来是什么样子，如何获得它。
And one of, to me, the most interesting questions about patience is, why are we so quick to say we don't have it? So most of us, you know, wouldn't quickly say that we are, you know, cowardly or unkind or ungenerous. But lots of people, myself included, will happily say we're inpatients, which makes it kind of a funny virtue. So those are just some of the things we're digging into in the coming years. Wow, that all sounds really fascinating. So we'll have to stay in touch and keep an eye on your research so that we can talk again when you're you've got some big breakthrough, which I'm sure you will get to. So thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Sweeney.
而且对我来说，关于耐心最有趣的问题之一是，为什么我们这么快就说我们没有它？所以我们大多数人，你知道，不会很快说我们是，你知道，懦弱、不友善或吝啬的。但很多人，包括我自己，会很高兴地说我们是“不耐烦的”，这使它成为一种有趣的美德。所以这些只是我们未来几年要挖掘的一些事情。哇，听起来都很迷人。所以我们必须保持联系，密切关注你的研究，这样当你有了一些重大突破时，我们可以再次交谈，我相信你一定会做到的。所以非常感谢你今天加入我们，斯威尼博士。
This was fun. Thanks so much for having me. You can read more about Dr. Sweeney's work in the November 2021 issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. You'll find a link in the show notes on our website at www.combeatingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Pandora, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman.
这很有趣。非常感谢邀请我。您可以在2021年11月出版的美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》中阅读更多关于斯威尼博士的研究成果。您可以在我们网站www.speakingofpsychology.org的节目说明中找到链接。您也可以在Apple、Stitcher、Pandora或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学访谈》往期节目。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由李·怀纳曼制作。
Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。